She put herself in danger in the pursuit
of a good story. She uncovered wrongs,
committed in society.
She traveled around the world and she
did it all in a time when women weren't
expected to do anything beyond
get married, have children,
and take care of the home. She
lives her life, very different men.
She faced backlash, but she never
backs down and she'd changed lives.
Energy changed journalism forever.
Well,
he wants this courageous woman that
would of course be nearly blind or women
ahead of our time.
No,
though it's the name
she's best known as today.
Nellie Bly wasn't actually born as such.
After birth in 1864 she was christened
Elizabeth Jane Cochran and growing up she
was indeed known by a different name
altogether and that would be pink.
She was a vibrant, energetic Charles.
You've never shied from attention.
Her mother encouraged her vivaciousness
and allowed her to dress in bright
colors. Most of the girls and women in
her home town of Cochrane in Pennsylvania,
we're wearing drab colors of brown,
black, gray, and white, but it's pink.
Stood out. She had to, she
had 13 brothers and sisters.
To contend with for attention after all.
The town was actually named after
blaze Father Judge Michael Cochran.
Judge Cochran unfortunately passed away
at an early age and Bly was only six
years old when it happens. Per father
did not have a will and his death left.
The family impoverished.
Blaze mother remarried,
but it's the marriage turned out to
be a disaster and new husband's blind.
Step father was a violent drunk when
blinds mother had finally had enough of
this mistreatment. She filed for
divorce that's only 14 years old,
but I was called upon to
testify at the divorce trial.
She had to speak up about what she had
seen this violent man do and how he had
mistreated her mother,
true to her personality.
Even then she was honest and witty even
in what must have been an incredibly
difficult situation for a young teenager.
During the trial, she told the court,
my stepfather has been generally drunk
since he married my mother and when drunk
he is very cross,
he is cross save it to the whole law deal.
Made an impression on Bly in the year
where she was living in marriage was
supposed to be the
ultimate goal for a woman.
Having seen how mother's experiences blind
knew that marriage didn't always need
a secure future or even happiness blinds.
She decided that she was going to make
her mark on the world all by herself.
Initially went to school for a
career in teaching for a woman.
That was one of the only career
path is available at the time.
She was a good writer,
but she wasn't a good student.
Then after only one semester,
she couldn't afford the tuition and
so her mother needed help at home,
so she had to leave school.
She moved with her mother and siblings
to Pittsburgh where they ran a boarding
house for income.
Once a blight picks up a local
newspaper and was a gas at column,
she rat the title.
It was enough to set her off because
it was what girls are good for.
The actual contents.
Well,
those what outright angering the column
asserted that women were good for
nothing.
That's staying at home and giving birth
and when it came to working women, well,
the radical them,
a monstrosity blind.
She wasn't one to sit idly by and let
something she disagreed with as much as
this PA spine. She drafted up a response
using the pseudonym, lonely often girl.
Her response caught the attention
of the papers editor George Madden,
but Ashley had risen.
It's under a pseudonym.
He had no way to identify
and get in touch with blind.
He was so impressed though
that he didn't give up.
He was an advertisement and the Pittsburgh
dispatch asking Lingley often go to
contacts and the paper and to reveal her
identity and well, why did he do this?
When he wants to give her a job by
responding to the advertisements and was
given the chance to write
a column on a trial basis,
after I call them was published
in the Pittsburgh dispatch,
not an highlighter for a full time job.
While at the dispatch Cochran officially
adopted the name that the world would
come to remember.
Of course that would be Nellie Bly.
She worked for only $5 a week,
but she had a platform to share her
ideas about women's independence.
Lie also began the work that would
make her famous outing social wrongs.
As an undercover reporter.
She combines the two messages by going
undercover as a factory worker and
writing an expo,
say on the poor conditions that women
faced as they tried to and pennies to help
feed the families.
Jolson writes about the unfair
treatments of women who were in divorce
proceedings.
That topic,
she knew a thing or two about us
because of her mother's experience.
Bonton and articles were controversial
and advertisers don't like controversy.
Sound familiar?
They started to pull their ads from the
dispatch and the publisher got nervous
if she was going to cause
problems for their bottom line.
They didn't see the value
in keeping Bly in this role.
That was so atypical
for a woman at the time,
so they put a women writers usually works
the fashion and society pages blind,
wasn't really happy with this
move in 1887 is only 23 years old.
She moved by herself to New York City.
She didn't have a job,
but when she went to the big city, in
fact, she was unemployed for months.
She wasn't willing to give up there and
it's kept visiting offices and applying
for work. After four
months, she hit the Jackpot.
The New York world offered to let her
try out an assignment run by Joseph
Pulitzer. The paper was a prominent
publication as Bly. She was up to the job.
One of our first assignments at the New
York world's became her most famous.
It also made a difference with the
treatments of some of society's most
vulnerable people in
the late 19th century.
The mentally ill were locked
up and isolated from society.
One place they were sent in New York
was the women's lunatic asylum on
Blackwell's island and blinds or editors.
Well,
they want you to get
into that institution.
She was eager to do so even though she
didn't know how she was going to get out.
All she was told in preparation for this
assignment was write up things as you
find them good or bad.
Give praise and blame as you think
best as the truth. All the time.
She spent days preparing,
practicing facial expressions to make
herself seem as out of it as possible.
Then she went to a boarding
house to spend the night.
While there she pretended to be
afraid of everything at the house.
She spent hours just staring at the
wall and saying nothing in shorts.
She somebody did her best to act insane.
It works and the head of the boarding
house called the cops and Bly was taken
away. The police had around analyzed
by doctors at the Bellevue Hospital.
Bly claims to have an easier and so
case caught the attention of the media.
They knew one recognized
her as a journalist.
Ultimately the doctors were able to
recommends that this young pretty
independently insane women, the
committed to Blackwell island. Now,
even before she arrived at the asylum,
she had her first bit of
information for her expos.
A asylums apparently weren't
all that hard to get into.
When she arrived at this observation
was cemented for her as she knows other
patients.
He didn't seem to have all that much
reason to be locked up and away from
society once she was in the asylum blind.
Did an act at all.
She decided to just be
herself and interestingly this
didn't arouse suspicion at
all. In fact, it actually did the
opposite lay days are observed.
The more seemingly I talked in actors,
the crazier I was thought to be daily
life. It was tough at the asylum.
I was forced into cold
barbs and was freezing.
Most of the time that she was committed,
my teeth shattered and my limbs were
boost, flashed with blue and cold.
Suddenly I got one after the other three
buckets of water over my head, ice,
cold water to and to my ears,
my eyes, my nose and my mouth.
The food was horrific.
Dirty water served alongside rotting
meat grool ans nearly inedible bread.
Patient states and areas surrounded by
waste and with rats crawling around their
fees.
Their days were spent sitting on hard
benches and some patients were even tied
together in her initial newspaper reports
and it's later in a published book.
Bly described the horrific treatment of
asylum patients and how it's might be
making the patients even worse.
She wrote what accepting torture would
produce insanity quicker than this
treatments. Here is a class
of women sent it to be cured.
I would like the expert physicians
who are condemning me for my action,
which has proven their ability to take
a perfectly sane and healthy women,
shut her up and make us sit from 6:00
AM to 8:00 PM on straight back benches.
Did Not allow her to talk
or move during these hours.
Give her no reading and his letter,
no nothing of the world or it's doing
give her bad food and harsh treatment and
see how long it will
take to make her insane.
Two months would make her a
mental and physical wreck,
but I lasted 10 days of Blackwell islands.
She was released when the paper contacted
the asylum and asked for her release
two weeks days and the piece was published
in the New York worlds and it grabs
the attention of the country. People were
outraged and we're calling for change.
Your grand jury was convened and Bly
joins them in devising a series of changes
that needed to be made at the asylum.
The New York Department of charities and
corrections had $1 million out into its
budget to help with
improvements to the facilities.
The turnover oversaw and overall safer
and more humane conditions and treatments
were implemented at the asylums blind,
the Caymus celebrity.
She was praised for her bravery and her
willingness to speak out about societal
ills, but her work was far
from over. Even with our fame,
she keeps up undercover reporting.
The same year she went
down to cover the asylum.
Blind also went undercover for
a piece of a lighter nature.
She wants it to find out about the
active industry in New York City,
that sorts of fines,
women husbands, she wrote,
this has been getting interested me.
I didn't know what to marry,
but I was as interested as a little
boy with a dynamites cartridge.
On another occasion she wrote about a
Sadden York industry baby buying and she
indeed to come the New York government
exposing the actions that were prominent
lobbyist who was essentially
bribing lawmakers.
Nellie Bly had no shortage of topics to
write on and is no shortage of courage.
Do you drive a forward
in her investigations but
her appetite for adventure
wasn't fully sated by writing articles
about the CD goings on of New York City
in 1888 she was 24 years
old and she has an idea,
she wants it to travel around the wells
and she wants it to do it faster than
Jewel's vins fictional character,
affiliates fog.
And of course she wanted to
write about it in the paper.
Although she's proven herself
from her past assignments, blight,
it's still faced reticence
from editors within working.
It was quite difficult for the times.
Women traveling by themselves was adding
a new layer of defiance to the Norse.
They wanted to send a man around the
world and not nearly as she later wrote.
The to her request was along the lines
of it is impossible for you to do.
It was the terrible
verdicts in the first place.
You are a woman and you would need a
protector and even if it were possible for
you to travel alone,
you would need to carry so much baggage
that it would detain you and making
rapid changes besides you speak.
Nothing but English,
so there is no use talking about it.
No one but a man.
We can do this and so what was their
response to this very well start the man
and I'll start the same day if some
other newspaper and to beat him.
It took a year but her is were eventually
convinced that she could make the
journey and that's I'm women traveled
with suitcases full of clothes and we're
often attended by escorts,
but again showed that she was ahead of
her time when the time came for her to
depart on her trip around the world.
In 1899 she boarded the ship or Augusta
Victoria by herself and with only two
small bags.
She wore a since and I ever coached and
kept a few $100 in a bag tied around her
neck. The first part of our
trip though it was tough,
but I got seasick and
couldn't hold down food.
The only thing that made her feel better,
we're sleeping.
At one point she slept for so long that
the ship's crew thought that she had
died in our cabin. She landed in
England's and went on to France in France.
She imagined Jewel's van,
the man who inspired the trip from France.
She traveled to Egypt,
say long Hong Kong and Japan and China.
She visited a lab colony along the way.
She traveled to board ships and rickshaws
and trains even riding horses when
needed to back home in the United States.
So readership was kept updated
via telegraph. All the time,
Bly was traveling the world.
People were keeping a close eye on the
dispatchers that she sends from abroad.
They had more than a passing interest
in her venture for van was a prize at
stake if the New York world's and
decided to make the most of blaze trip to
drive up their audience
and build their brands.
They offered a trip to Europe for the
person who was places to guessing and
blinds returns.
I'm starting points.
People made guesses literally
down to the seconds. Meanwhile,
they were also following another trip
around the world. Upon hearing of blinds,
stunts,
arrival in New York newspaper decided
they couldn't let the New York world to
get all the attention,
so they sent a female reporter of their
own around the globe and there's the
business left New York
heading the opposite way,
traversing the United States first before
heading across the Pacific business,
Lindsey took four days longer
than Bli to travel the world.
The final leg of blades global
trip was across the Pacific Ocean.
She made her way across the world's
largest ocean on the RMS oceanic,
but the ship hit rough
weather on the crossing.
Bly was two days later than she had
plans for her arrival back to the u s she
doesn't box in San Francisco
and boarded a private train.
Take her back to the east coast.
72 days after departing aboard
a ship and Hoboken New Jersey,
she was back not only hip, she'd beats
in Phineas fogs fictional record.
She had set a world record of her own.
Indeed Nellie Bly had once again proven.
Her niece says wrong.
She said,
I always have a comfortable feeling that
nothing is impossible if one applies a
certain amount of energy in the right
direction. When I want things done,
which is always at the last moment,
and as I am met with such an answer,
it's too late. I hardly think it
can be done. I simply say, nonsense.
If you want to do it, you can do it. The
question is, do you want to do it? Well,
I published a book about her adventure
and the New York world was happy with the
increased attention they
receive thanks to [inaudible],
but apparently they were not happy to
give blood a bonus insulted to this.
She resigned. She didn't have a job, but
she wasn't suffering quite the opposite.
She had become a national celebrity,
I religion name were worth money.
So popular had she become
with her adventure around
the world and by this point
she wasn't even 30 within three years
of our departure. Then New York wealth.
While they wanted her back,
she started writing for the paper
again in 1893 once again taking on
investigative assignments and these
assignments had the goal of reaching out
corruption and miss treatments.
No,
although she had always said that she
had no plans to Mary and had Indeed's
lived out her life in defiance of the
expectations of women by eventually matter
man and decided to settle down. In 1995
she met and married a 73 year old man.
Lied was just 31 oh husband's Roger
Seaman was the head of the iron class
manufacturing industry.
Marriage doesn't mean that blight was
ready to become a housewife and it's not
work. Quite the opposite. In fact,
she started to get involved with the
manufacturing company offering designs for
products and helping oversee
its operations to of the
designs she created with a
company with passengers and Milka
cat and then the garbage can.
In 1896 she quits working for the New
York world's to focus more of our time.
The ironclads manufacturing company.
When her husband died in 1904 she even
took over as its president how time in
that role and lasted less than a decade
as the company filed for bankruptcy in
1911 when the company failed blind jumps
right back into what she knew best and
that was reporting the women's
suffrage movement was in full swing.
Man's Bly wrote about the marches and
calls for the vote in the latter half of
the 1910s she covered world war one
giving her another groundbreaking title.
She was the first female war
correspondent in the United States,
fully back into journalism.
She got her own column in The New York
Journal in 1919 but sadly her sounds are
writing. Didn't last long. In 1922
when she was only 57 years old,
blind contracted pneumonia.
The oldest would prove to be the only
thing that keep her down on January the
27th 1922 by lost her life to pneumonia
at saint Mark's hospital in New York
City. Physically, the next day's
edition. If the evening journal Coulter,
the best reporter in America,
no Danny Bly
was a trailblazer.
Not just for women,
but for all journalists are writing
made a difference in people's lives
affecting change in government
and inspiring and lighting
people's imaginations
from an early age.
She showed great courage.
She knew what she wants it and she
went for it. That doing nothing,
especially not the fact that she
was a woman stand in our way.
How she was a writer, perhaps her
own words sum up her life best.
I said I could and I worked and I did so
I really hope you enjoyed that episode
of biographics. If you did, there's a
couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also, if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube. If you actually want to
get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time, every Monday
and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also, if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.